so since we were talking about Twitter
uh Elon Musk had what I think a few
harsh wards
that I wish he didn't say so let me ask
uh in in hope in the name of camaraderie
what do you think Elon is doing well
with Twitter and what as a person who
has run for a long time you social
networks
Facebook Instagram WhatsApp
uh what can he do better what can he
improve on that text-based social
network gosh it's always very difficult
to offer specific critiques from from
the outside before you get into this
because I think one thing that I've
learned
is that
everyone has opinions on what you should
do and
like running the company you see a lot
of specific nuances on things that are
not apparent externally and
um I often
think that some of the discourse around
us would be
could be better if if there was more
kind of space for acknowledging that
there's certain things that we're seeing
internally that guide what we're doing
but
um but I don't know I mean because since
you asked what what is what is going
well
um
you know I I do think that Elon led a
push early on to make Twitter a lot
leaner and
um and I think that that
you know it's like you can you can agree
or disagree with exactly all the tactics
and how and how we did that you know
obviously you know every leader has
their own style for if they you know if
you need to make dramatic changes for
that how you're going to execute it
um but a lot of the specific principles
that he pushed on
um around
basically trying to make the
organization more technical around
decreasing the distance between
Engineers of the company and and him
like fewer layers of management
um
I think that those were generally good
changes and I'm also
I also think that it was probably good
for the industry that he made those
changes because my sense is that there
were a lot of other people who thought
that those were good changes
but who may have been
a little shy about
doing them and I think he
um you know just in my conversations
with other Founders
um and how people have reacted to the
things that we've done you know what
I've heard from a lot of folks is is
just hey you know when you when someone
like you you know when I wrote the
letter outlining the organizational
changes that I wanted to make
um back in March and when people see
what Elon is doing
um I think that that gives
you know people
the ability to Think Through how to
shape their organizations in in a way
that um that that you know hopefully can
can be good for the industry and make
all these companies more productive over
time so
um something that that was one where I
think he was
um quite ahead of of a bunch of the the
other companies on and and you know what
he was doing there
you know again from the outside very
hard to know it's like okay did he did
he cut too much did he knock enough
whatever I I don't think it's like my
place to opine on that
um and and you asked for a for a
positive framing of the question of of
what what do I um what do I admire what
do I think it went well but I I think
that like certainly his actions
um
led me and I think a lot of other folks
in the industry to think about hey are
we are we kind of doing this as much as
we should like can we is it like could
we make our companies better by pushing
on some of these same principles
well the two of you are in the top of
the world in terms of leading the
development of tech and I wish there was
more uh both way camaraderie and
kindness uh more love in the world
because love is the answer